guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Donnerstagabend zu gewohnter Zeit gut
dass sie wieder mit dabei sind wir
werden
ärmer werden sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister denn er weiß
die Zeiten sind vorbei da die Russen uns
billiges Gas lieferten die Amerikaner
für unsere Verteidigung zahlten und die
Chinesen einfach so unsere Autos kauften
deutschland verliert im globalen
Wettbewerb wenn es sich nicht neu
erfindet wie das die Deutsche Bank
gerade versucht die backt mittlerweile
kleinere Brötchen und ihren Chef
Christian seving begrüße ich genauso
herzlich wie den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
zu einer sehr besonderen Sendung in sehr
besonderen Zeiten Herr seving fangen wir
an 2008 man erinnert sich dunkel wurden
Banken gerettet mit Steuergeld jetzt
werden
Energieversorger gerettet mit unendlich
vielen Milliarden was ist das für eine
Wirtschaft die in jeder Krise gerettet
werden muss
zunächst einmal ist es nicht so dass in
jeder Krise die Wirtschaft gerettet
werden muss
2008 war die Finanzkrise wir waren Teil
des Problems gar keine Frage ich glaube
danach sind die richtigen
regulatorischen aber auch Konsequenzen
in den Banken gezogen worden dass wir
heute in dieser Zeit Teil der Lösung
sind
wir haben eine wirkliche
Ausnahmesituation das muss man schon
sagen ausgelöst durch den Krieg und von
daher ist es glaube ich richtig dass man
auch unverschuldet in die Krise
gekommene Unternehmen jetzt rettet damit
sozusagen auch den Wettbewerb noch vorne
und die Möglichkeit nach vorne sich zu
entwickeln sicherstellt und von daher
glaube ich ist es keine neue Art des
Kapitalismus sondern ein richtiger
Entschluss aber sie haben recht das kann
nicht immer das Schema sein das kann
nicht immer die Lösung sein deswegen
müssen wir in unserer langfristigen
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit arbeiten die
Menschen in dieser Krise erarbeitet
haben in aller erster Linie viele Sorgen
weil ihr Satz war die
krisentürmen sich auf in dieser Welt und
ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht wo man
anfangen soll sich Sorgen zu machen und
also braucht man viel Vertrauen glauben
Sie dass die Bürger dieses Landes ihnen
noch vertrauen
erst einmal das kriegen in Europa und
ein Ausfall der Energiemengen in hohen
Mengen zu beklagen das heißt wir sind
wirklich in einer Sondersituation
und ich finde trotz alledem hat dieses
Land sich
außerordentlich bewährt in den
verschiedenen Institutionen in den
Prozessen die wir verabredet haben also
in dem Zusammenspiel zwischen Bund und
Ländern und es sind eben auch viele
Entscheidungen sehr schnell getroffen
worden die jetzt dafür gesorgt haben
dass die Situation
beherrschbarer das ist relativ
gesprochen ja müssen man kann hier noch
gar nicht durchatmen und sagen die Krise
ist vorbei oder wir haben es ungefähr
beherrschbarer zu Beginn des Winters ist
als sie hätte sein können wenn wir nicht
so gehandelt hätten als Land meine Frage
erinnern sie glauben Sie dass die
Menschen in diesem Land ihnen noch
vertrauen
der Bundesregierung Ihnen persönlich den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
die Frage ist mache ich meinen Job für
das Land und ich tue das wenn sie sich
eben mit den Sorgen der Menschen
befassen wollen die haben in aller
erster Linie eine sehr große Sorge und
das ist die Finanzierbarkeit Ihrer
Energiekosten denken sie dass diese
größte Sorge adäquat und schnell und
effizient gelöst wurde von der
Bundesregierung und auch von ihrem
Wirtschaftsminister ich glaube dass
verschiedene sorgen gleichzeitig da
waren und sich in dem Wechselspiel
nichts geschenkt haben Sorge vor Krieg
Sorge vor Atomkrieg Sorge vor fehlende
Energie dann hätten wir über Preise gar
nicht groß reden müssen wir hätten
nichts gehabt
und natürlich jetzt die hohen Preise die
Bundesregierung hat alles drei zusammen
jeweils bedacht und ich auch wenn sie
mich persönlich ansprechen von Anfang an
so dass wir am Anfang schon der Krise
Entlastung auch bei dem Preisen gemacht
haben wir haben entlastungspakete im Mai
meine ich im Mai nein nein nein nein die
Leute jetzt noch diese 300 Euro
war hat die Bundesregierung rechtzeitig
gehandelt und das hat sie getan wir
haben im Mai das erste entlassungspaket
gemacht 30 Milliarden eine Menge Holz
klar jetzt haben wir 200 Milliarden aber
30 Milliarden nicht zu vergessen wir
haben die Umlage abgeschafft wir haben
die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas abgeschafft
all das haben wir schon getan über den
Sommer das heißt wir haben wir haben die
Preiskrise von Anfang an adressiert
die Leute gegebenenfalls nicht mehr sie
befürchtet uns gemeinsam
aber trotzdem wurde ja gehandelt auch
wenn man ist vergisst gab es ja eine
Handlung das ist ja nicht weg zu
diskutieren das ist eine Handlung gab
ich wollte jetzt nicht gleich mit dem
nächsten Argument kommen und sagen es
gab im Sommer die Situation dass man
sich viel zu lange mit etwas befasst hat
was nicht eine Lösung dieses Problems
Palette da kommen wir auf jeden Fall
noch und wollte Christian sie wegen
natürlich auch nach der Verantwortung
als Manager Fragen zu dieser zu diesem
Vertrauen in einer solchen Krise gehört
natürlich auch
Image und gehört
Verantwortungsbewusstsein und das gilt
nicht nur bei Politikern sondern auch
ihre Bank hatte damit in der
Vergangenheit schwer zu kämpfen
seriös und verlässlich bankwerbung aus
den 90ern vertrauen ist der Anfang von
allem Deutsche Bank doch das Vertrauen
schwankt bald Skandale wie Mannesmann
Schneider und Kirch waren nur der Anfang
mit
us-schrott-immobilienkrediten drehte die
Bank das ganz große Rad bis zum Crash
die Deutsche Bank hatte in USA diese
Produkte mit kreiert denn damals faul
Immobilienkredite gesammelt worden sind
hat sie so verpackt dass man nicht mehr
genau wusste was drin ist und hat es
dann verkauft die Folge Banken Pleiten
staatliche Rettungsaktionen und
Milliarden Strafen für die Deutsche Bank
in den USA
und damit nicht genug
zinsmanipulationen Betrug mit
CO2-Zertifikaten
Geldwäsche für gute russische Kunden
all das fiel in die Ära von Josef
Ackermann und seinen Leuten
Unterführung von Herrn Ackermann hat
sich die ehemals seriöse Deutsche Bank
in eine kriminogene Zockerbude
verwandelt
vertrauen ist der Anfang von allem damit
war die Deutsche Bank sie sind auch
Präsident des Bankenverbandes hier in
Deutschland
würden Sie sagen dass tatsächlich dieser
Branche weiter so vertraut werden kann
nach all diesen Schäden die es da
gegeben hat
ja ich glaube zunächst einmal müssen wir
zu unseren Fehlern stehen die wir
gemacht haben und ich habe nie ein Hehl
daraus gemacht dass auch die Deutsche
Bank Fehler gemacht hat gerade an den in
den Anfang der 2000er die wir auch zum
Teil zu spät aufgeräumt haben ich glaube
wir haben jetzt aber
nicht nur aufgeräumt sondern haben ja
die Bank ganz neu aufgestellt machen die
Geschäfte wo die Kunden wirklich von uns
sich wünschen dass wir diese Geschäfte
mit den Kunden machen und deutlich äh
kundenzentrierter und haben dadurch
natürlich auch es geschafft sozusagen
wir Vertrauen zurück zu gewinnen und das
Zeichnen nicht nur die Ergebnisse das
ist der eine Teil der natürlich
erfreulich ist aber es ist insbesondere
auch das Feedback und die Rückmeldung
der Kunden die wir bekommen ist einfach
sagen die Deutsche Bank ist zurück mit
der Deutschen Bank arbeiten wir gerne
wir waren gerade in Asien zusammen auf
dem Asien Pazifik Kongress in Singapur
sieht unheimlich viele Mittelständler
die eine globale Bank mit so einem
Netzwerk haben möchten und ich glaube
mit unserer Rückbesinnung mit der klaren
Aufarbeitung der Fehler auch mit
personellen Konsequenzen die wir gezogen
haben sind wir auf dem richtigen Weg
aber sie werden nie von mir hören dass
wir keine Fehler gemacht haben dazu
stehen wir und die immer aufgeräumt und
kann man das heute irgendwie auch so
präzise überwachen es hat jetzt allein
in diesem Jahr zwei Razzien gegeben
einmal in Bezug auf cumex und einmal in
einer bei der DWS
würden Sie sagen es besteht eigentlich
auch immer die Gefahr in so einem
Unternehmen das ist tatsächlich auch
andere neue Krisenfälle für sie geben
kann die sie dann halt entscheiden
müssen ja es ist natürlich nicht leicht
zu sagen aber wenn Sie ein Unternehmen
weltweit führen mit 85.000 Mitarbeitern
dann würde ich niemals sagen Frau Illner
dass wir fehlerfrei sein wir müssen
besser werden wir sind deutlich besser
geworden wir haben enorme Summen in
unsere Kontrollen richtigerweise
investiert ich glaube die Regulatoren
haben uns richtigerweise angewiesen
resiliente robuster zu werden und ich
glaube diese Verfehlungen die wir in der
Vergangenheit gemacht haben für die wir
hohe Strafen bezahlt haben
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
nach vorne hin noch genauso passieren
dass ich aber alle Fehler ausschließe
das kann ich nicht wir haben es wird
Menschen zu tun die gar nicht bewusst
auf Fehler machen sondern zum Teil
einfach Fehler passieren wir müssen nur
schnell reagieren und vor ihnen wir
müssen sie zugeben und wenn wir sie
zugeben und arbeiten ein erster Schritt
genau und ich glaube das ist doch genau
so wie sie ihre Kinder erziehen genauso
müssen sie das meines ernst mit einer
Bankführung dann auch machen dass man
wenn man Fehler macht muss man dazu
stehen ändern aufräumen und dann einen
besseren Weg nach vorne machen und genau
das haben wir in der Deutschen Bank
gemacht sie haben gesagt in ihrem
Berufsleben haben sie nie mehr Risiken
und Unsicherheiten gesehen als heute
damit darf ich sie zitieren wenn man so
viele Milliarden verspricht wenn man
diese 300 Milliarden in die Hand nimmt
den Doppelpunkt in die Hand nimmt und
die Bürger dennoch so unzufrieden sind
sind wir dann gut regiert in diesem Land
also zunächst einmal möchte ich sagen
dass ich ich weiß gar nicht ob die
Bürger so unzufrieden sind das ist
natürlich eine enorme Unsicherheit die
wir haben eine Inflation von über zehn
Prozent ist etwas was die meisten Bürger
also nicht kennengelernt haben und
leider müssen wir auch davon ausgehen
dass diese Inflation in der Höhe bis
Februar März nächsten Jahr so bleiben
wird und wir auch im Jahr 2023 Inflation
von siebeneinhalb Prozent noch haben
werden im Schnitt das und das kreiert
natürlich Unsicherheit aber ich möchte
schon sagen denn das was hier passiert
ist in den letzten 12 Monaten an
geopolitischen Unsicherheiten der
furchtbare Krieg immer noch
lieferkettenprobleme durch coburgit die
Inflation die ich gerade angesprochen
habe das ist natürlich etwas was sie
nicht irgendwo in einem Textbuch haben
wo sie einfach mal die Lösung links und
rechts ausschütten und ich muss
ehrlicherweise sagen ich glaube die
Bundesregierung hat insgesamt sehr
ordentlich agiert hat schnell reagiert
wir müssen jetzt unbedingt die
unmittelbare Krise im Sinne der
inflationsbe Prüfung angehen das ist
wirklich was was wir aus dem System
rauskriegen müssen deswegen ist die
Reaktion der Zentralbank richtig und
gleichzeitig die wird getrieben
entschuldigung ich unterbreche damit wir
nicht sofort über die Inflation reden
sondern erstmal sagen die wird getrieben
natürlich durch die hohen Energiepreise
die Menschen stehen im Grunde ja davor
ihre Rechnungen bezahlen zu müssen die
Ankündigung haben wir gerade schon
gemacht Dezember Abschlag soll es geben
Herr Habeck um den Leuten die Sorge zu
nehmen in diese Situation jetzt im
Grunde nichts im Portemonnaie zu haben
wann kommt dieser Dezember Abschlag nein
im Dezember deswegen heißt
wir haben bitte november ist
ein bisschen weiter sie schaffen das
überhaupt nicht
verwirrt weil die gaskommission hat ja
einen positiven Vorschlag gemacht im
Dezember wird der Abschlag nicht erhoben
das heißt er kommt nicht sondern er wird
nichts passiert also die Abschläge die
wir auf die Gasrechnung diejenigen die
Gas haben bezahlen müssen werden im
Dezember nicht eingelassen
bis dahin aber organisieren dass die
Versorger alle die 1800 insgesamt dass
sie auf jeden Fall das Geld vom Staat
bekommen um die Kunden weiter beliefern
zu können und das geschieht zielgenau
und zu diesem Zeitpunkt im Dezember das
ist der Plan jetzt müssen die Versorger
der
auszahlenden Stelle das wird die Café
sein
melden ich würde sagen geschätzt melden
was die abschlagshöhe ist also die die
Abschläge die nicht einkassiert werden
wir wissen ja nicht welche Stadtwerke
welche Summen von ihren Kunden bekommen
und dann kriegen sie das Geld von der
Bundesregierung dass sie die Versorgern
nicht einen Monat lang keine Einnahmen
haben und dann werden die Einnahmen
nicht kassiert natürlich braucht das
auch etwas Zeit in der Überweisung jetzt
haben wir Mitte November
kann gut gelingen das wissen jetzt ja
alle seit geraumer Zeit also die
Versorger wissen auch dass sie diesen
Antrag jetzt stellen müssen sollte ein
Antrag erst am 29 November bei der KfW
Bank eingehen kann ich nicht garantieren
das am ersten Dezember das Geld da ist
aber sie gehen
es ist lange geplant alle sind darauf
vorbereitet jetzt muss es natürlich
funktionieren das sind jetzt Menschen
die ihre Maschinen bedienen müssen und
ansonsten ist es ein bisschen wie er sie
wegen sagt
das Regelwerk ist konsistent
und dann müssen wir vielleicht auch mal
ein bisschen großzügig mit den
Abschlägen sein beziehungsweise auch Mut
zur Lücke haben wir werden in dieser
Krise nie agieren können wenn wir immer
nur agieren wenn wir hundertprozentig
bis auf die Kommastelle hinaus sicher
sind dass alles richtig und ausgerechnet
ist deswegen würde ich den Stadtwerken
sagen grobe Teilung reicht schon und
dann kriegt ihr den Abschlag und dann
rechnen wir danach im Januar oder im
Februar spitz ab das keiner soll in
Schieflagen geraten von den Versager
aber wichtig ist eben dass das Geld
jetzt schnell fertig schnell fließt und
dann empfehlen Sie quasi einen auf
runden oder abrunden auf jeden Fall
gerundete Beträge bis dahin hat eine
Kommission eine Expertenkommission
gearbeitet das haben sie verfolgt liebe
Zuschauer um eben dafür zu sorgen dass
es so etwas wie Gas und Strompreis
Bremsen in diesem Land gibt und das war
nicht ganz so einfach
eine Expertenkommission erfand die
gaspreisbremse sie verteilt viel Geld
per Gießkanne an alle gerecht ist das
nicht Gießkanne
das kommt das gehört zu den Prioritäten
die ich genannt habe ja wir sehen das
nein wir wollten es nicht aber ja wir
konnten es nicht vermeiden ab März
sollen 80% des Gasverbrauchs auf 12 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde gedeckelt werden aber
noch immer ist nicht klar wie es im
nächsten Jahr weitergeht die Regierung
wollte die Gas und strompreisbremse
morgen beschließen doch erneut
verschoben
so diese Kommission Herr Habeck hat
keine gerechte Entlastung besorgen
können weil es so spät war nein was
nicht richtig das ist nicht richtig wir
bezahlen jetzt irgendwie von dem reichen
Bewohner dieses Landes die Beheizung des
Pools und die Beheizung des Hauses also
um diesen gerechtigkeitsvorwurf geht es
ja Analyse ist nicht richtig sie konnte
keine gerechte
Vorschlag machen weil die Versorger also
meistens die Stadtwerke nicht wissen wie
viele Menschen hinter den
haushaltsanschlüssen leben sie können
bei dem Gasverbrauch nicht ablesen ob
jemand alleine in einer großen Villa
wohnt und die schön heißt oder viele
Personen in einer WG wohnen und die
ähnlich viel Energie
erst recht nicht absehen ob die Leute
die dahinter wohnen ein hohes oder
niedriges Einkommen oder ein großer
unterschiedliches Vermögen haben diese
Daten haben die Stadtwerke nicht gerecht
wäre dass man also nach einem bestimmten
Gerechtigkeitsbegriff dass diejenigen
die besonders bedürftig sind besonders
viel bekommen aber diese Daten liegen
nicht vor und deswegen musste sich die
gaspreiskommission und die
Bundesregierung ganz genauso helfen und
wir helfen uns so dass wir jetzt
tatsächlich für alle die gleiche Logik
entwickeln da gibt es einen
gerechtigkeits eine
gerechtigkeitsunwucht die kann man nicht
weg diskutieren die wird gemindert indem
diejenigen die höhere Einkommen haben ab
75.000 Euro wir haben jetzt den Soli
Eintritt genommen die Gelder die sie vom
Staat bekommen versteuern müssen dann
geht noch mal der Anteil der Steuern Weg
das
kalibriert ist ein bisschen es ist nicht
super gerecht aber es gilt das gleiche
was ich gerade gesagt habe wir hätten
auch die Möglichkeit gehabt wenn wir es
gewollt hätten datenschutzrechtlich erst
einmal Meldung Meldebogen auszuteilen zu
sagen wie viele Menschen wohnen denn
dahinter was verdient ihr denn und ihr
müsst es sagen wir monatlich
aktualisieren den Menschen ziehen
zusammen die ziehen auseinander sie
sterben sie kriegen Kinder das wäre dann
super gerecht gewesen wenn diejenigen
nur nie Geld ausgezahlt deswegen genau
das hat die gaspreiskommission richtig
gemacht wir können doch in dieser Krise
nicht anders handeln als zu handeln und
ich finde unsere Handeln man kann das
alles kritisieren ja aber dann muss man
auch wissen was die Kritik für eine
Konsequenz hat nämlich das in der Regel
gar nichts passiert so wir gucken noch
mal Herr sebing ob ihnen als Unternehmer
und sie sind dann unter Garantie auch in
diesen Fragen sehr gut bewandert
tatsächlich nur eine solche Lösung
eingefallen ist noch mal da saß jetzt
eine Expertenkommission in einer
ziemlichen Zeitnot weil es musste erst
ein Dezember Abschlag erfunden werden
und dann in einem zweiten Schritt diese
Umlage weil man unter einem akuten
Zeitdruck war hätte es auch einen
pauschales energiegeld geben können was
dann jeder besteuert und versteuert und
ordnungsgemäß
hätte sicherlich geben können aber für
mich stellt sich die Frage etwas anders
und das kann ich Ihnen aus den ganzen
Kunden Meetings und Interaktion mit
unseren Kunden sagen es geht um
Schnelligkeit und es geht jetzt wirklich
darum dass wir gerade den ärmeren in
unseren in der Gesellschaft den
Konsumenten und den Verbrauchern aber
insbesondere den kleinen Unternehmen das
sind nicht die große Unternehmen in der
Regel das sind die kleinen Unternehmen
die keine Chance haben die höheren
Energiepreise nach vorne weiter zu geben
und vor einer das ist keine kapitalfrage
das ist eine unmittelbare
liquiditätsfrage und deswegen ist es
richtig das schnell gehandelt wird und
das meinte ich eben mit meiner Antwort
es gibt kein Textbuch für diese Krise
und auch das kann ich aus der Deutschen
Bank mal sagen wenn wir in einer Krise
gewesen sind 20 18 20 haben wir
sicherlich auch mal die ein oder andere
Entscheidung genommen die man vielleicht
im Nachhinein noch etwas detaillierter
und besser hätte nehmen können aber
jetzt geht es darum zu entscheiden Dinge
auszuzahlen damit diese Unternehmen eine
Chance haben in den nächsten 12 Monaten
ich frage nach einer Zeit die wir
verschenkt haben das haben ihnen ihre
Kunden und ihre Kollegen sicherlich auch
gesagt nämlich die des Sommers als wir
um eine gasumlage geredet haben um die
Gaskunden eben die Rettung der
Gasversorger bezahlen zu lassen Juniper
40 Milliarden da ist die kobbank damals
mit den 18 Milliarden noch ein Spaß
gewesen
wie sehr ist Zeit vergeudet worden
ja also im Nachhinein kann man natürlich
immer sagen dass man vielleicht noch den
Monat oder zwei Monate hätte schneller
sein müssen aber lassen mich einfach den
Blick vom Ausland mal auf Deutschland
geben da wird mittlerweile gesagt es
werden Entscheidungen getroffen es
werden richtige Entscheidung getroffen
wir müssen jetzt nur zwei Dinge machen
es ist diese unmittelbare
Krisenbekämpfung die man sicherlich noch
zwei drei Monate hätte vorziehen können
vielleicht auch noch mit einem
stringenteren und ähm klaren Weg aber
die zweite Frage ist wie ist die
langfristige Energieversorgung und wie
ist da die Wettbewerbern kann wir sind
noch mal beim Bundeswirtschaftsminister
da habe ich sie sind in der Situation
gewesen diese gasumlage über viele
Wochen und Monate zu erklären auch der
Öffentlichkeit zu erklären und sie sind
dafür sehr kritisiert worden jetzt noch
auch heute hier in dieser Sendung aber
auch von der Opposition dieses Landes
die hat regelmäßig gefordert man möge
den Stecker oder den Stecker ziehen und
sie entlassen so lange diese Gasanlage
noch in der Welt ist darauf haben sie
sehr emotional reagiert im Bundestag und
haben da haben reklamiert dass man nicht
im Fußballstadion sei und ob das noch
Oppositionsarbeit ist
wie allein waren sie in dieser Situation
etwas verteidigen zu müssen gasumlage
was ja eigentlich diese Ampel
vorgeschlagen hat ich will noch einmal
mir wenn ich das sagen darf ich wieder
keine Kritik machen mal ein bisschen
viel Vergangenheitsbewältigung ist alles
interessiert hat und so ja ja aber das
die Gasanlage ist jetzt Geschichte genau
ich erzähl's noch mal was die
Notwendigkeit war weil es insofern
interessant ist dass wir uns entlang von
Notwendigkeiten ja entscheiden müssen
große Gasversorgungsunternehmen in
Deutschland haben Gas in Russland
eingekauft von Gazprom
das sehr günstig war dieses Glas
angesprochen haben
deswegen ist es wichtig zu verstehen
dass man immer ein Alternativen denken
muss das Gas ist nicht mehr gekommen es
musste teuer eingekauft werden die
Verträge allerdings die diese
Unternehmen hatten waren zu dem
günstigen Konditionen getroffen worden
und irgendjemand musste die Differenz
zahlen wenn es niemand getan hätte hätte
die Hälfte der Leute keinen Gast
bekommen deswegen war die gasumlage
mangels Alternativen richtig sie war
richtig und was ich nicht richtig fand
damals war zu sagen macht doch keine
gasumlage weil das hätte bedeuten dass
die Hälfte von Deutschland kein Gas mehr
bekommen hätte und wenn sich niemand
mehr daran erinnert dass das Problem war
ich erinnere mich daran und es ist die
Aufgabe des Wirtschaftsministers die
Gasversorgung sicherzustellen wenn einer
eine andere Tiefe schafft die ist dann
geschaffen worden spät mit den 200
Milliarden und ein Teil daraus geht dann
freue ich mich es ist ja nicht so dass
man sich war mein erster Rede als ich
die vorgestellt habe dass ich eine
schlechte Nachricht verkünde hier mit
aber eine notwendige Nachricht und wenn
Sie Fragen bin ich auf das Thema der
Sendung kommen darf wie geht es
Deutschland oder wo stehen wir in
Deutschland dann finde ich es eine ja
wir haben einen Plan und der ist in
vieler Hinsicht sehr gut aufgegangen die
Speicher sind voll weil wir Gesetze
gemacht haben weil wir eingekauft haben
wir haben die ersten Infrastrukturen
geschaffen für alternative Gasversorgung
weil man sich Menschen reingehängt haben
und weil wir Geld dafür in die Hand
genommen haben als es noch keinen Markt
dafür gab wir haben die störungsaktion
von Putin bei Gasform Germania und bei
der Angriffe auf die Leitung immer
wieder mit konkreten Maßnahmen
beantwortet wir haben 300 Milliarden
Euro in die Hand genommen natürlich
haben die einen Plan nur und das man da
muss man sich entscheiden worauf man
guckt ich finde dass ich Deutschland
insgesamt die verschiedenen
Institutionen die Landesregierung die
Bundesregierung der Förderalismus der
das Zusammenspiel zwischen Wirtschaft
und Regierung bewährt hat bewährt hat
unter einer Bedingung
wo man in einem Feld dass man neu
beschritten hat wo man nicht ein
Wahlkampf darüber geführt hat wo der
Koalitionsvertrag keine Antworten
gegeben hat Entscheidungen treffen muss
dazu gehört die gasumlage deswegen noch
einmal sie war richtig da gibt es nichts
zu entschuldigen an der Stelle solange
es keine besseren Alternativen gab so
wie wir andere richtigen Entscheidungen
getroffen haben
wurde Juniper jetzt mit Staatsgeld
gezahlt also dieses Unternehmen ist
gesichert mit Staatsgeld das ist mit
diesen 200 Milliarden doppelwurms dann
erledigt und ermöglicht worden vorher
muss es jemand verhindert haben dieser
jemand ist der Bundesfinanzminister und
die Frage ist haben sie diese gasumlage
erfunden weil der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner nicht die
Verstaatlichung dieses Unternehmens
wollte ist doch eine ganz einfache Frage
da können sie also sie ich bin erstaunt
dass sie das noch verteidigen und sagen
diese Gasanlage war eine super Sache in
einer Krise muss man das tun was die
Krise gebietet und die Krise Gebot dass
ein großer Gasversorger wie uniper nicht
umfällt und dafür gab es denkt logisch
verschiedene Optionen die gasumlage war
unter den Bedingungen die wir damals
hatten die einzig wirklich umsetzbare
Optionen und jetzt haben wir etwas
später eine andere gefunden das ist auch
okay das tut dann ein bisschen weh es
rumpelt ein bisschen wir haben sozusagen
einen Weg korrigiert es wird aber wieder
passieren dass wir Wege korrigieren
müssen und ist ist die Frage ist die
Frage so ähnlich wie Herr sieding ist
für die Deutsche Bank dargestellt hat
ist es in dieser Republik ermöglicht
Wege zu korrigieren und wenn die Antwort
ja ist dann kann man darüber schreiben
aber das Gute ist doch wir finden
erfolgreich neue Wege und das ist wenn
man zurück schaut auf das Jahr wo man
sagen muss da hat die Opposition den
Beitrag geleistet und zwar einen guten
sie hat den Finger in die Wunde gelegt
die hat zwar nicht gefordert 200
Milliarden her sofort aber okay aber
insgesamt das ist doch die Frage kämpfen
wir uns hier als Land durch und ich
glaube das tun wir sehr erfolgreich gut
ich frage trotzdem noch mal Christian
Lindner hat das damals offensichtlich
verhindert wer ist schuld daran warum
hat Olaf Scholz sich nicht früher vor
diesem Vorschlag gestellt warum mussten
sie den als einziger alleine verteidigen
ich finde das völlig irre währenddessen
Fragen es interessiert mich überhaupt
nicht das interessiert sie nicht okay
aber es haben sich ganz viele gefragt
warum wir über Wochen und Monate eine
gasumlage diskutierten weil Jule per
gerettet werden musste okay und ist
mangelt Alternativen nur diesen Weg gab
und dann haben wir eine Alternative
geschaffen und das wird wieder passieren
und das eine Regierung eine das
Zusammenspiel der demokratischen
Institution auf dem Weg dahin
miteinander Ring das ist Debatten gibt
dass sie Debatten manchmal weh tun ich
glaube das nennt man Demokratie völlig
in Ordnung so das ist erstaunlich ich
kann nur noch mal sagen ich finde
erstaunlich dass sie sagen das ist in
der Logik der Dinge auch bis heute für
sie eine
eine gute Lösung gewesen Herr sewing wir
fragen uns noch mal Stichwort
gaspreisbremse
da hat diese Expertenkommission
entschuldigung das war der
Sachverständigenrat der jetzt diese
schöne Idee gehabt wie gerecht ist das
zu sagen die Reichen müssten zusätzlich
belastet werden also auch der die
Sachverständigenkommission sagte ja das
ist keine besonders Wirtschaftsweise es
ist keine besonders gerechte Lösung wir
müssten bei der gaspreisbremse darüber
nachdenken ob es nicht in Energie Soli
gibt oder eine Steuererhöhung bei den
Reichen
hoch interessant sie sind auch im
Präsidium des CDU Wirtschaftsrates
denken Sie dass es eigentlich eine gute
Sache wäre sind sie dabei der
Bundesregierung oder sind Sie bei der
CDU die protestiert natürlich und Bayern
Linda der protestiert der findet es auch
abwegig
also zunächst einmal ist es glaube ich
völlig normal dass bei diesen Dingen die
vorgefallen sind und wie jetzt geholfen
wird dass ich diese Frage stellt und das
ist ja völlig normale ich finde das auch
richtig das ist dort der
unterschiedliche Meinung gibt ich glaube
bei der Besteuerung hat ja eben der
Wirtschaftsminister richtigerweise
gesagt dass zunächst einmal ein Weg
gefunden worden ist dass die
Unterstützung für die deutlich besser
verdienenden jetzt besteuert wird das
ist gut hätte man vielleicht genauso wie
es gesagt hätte noch einen anderen Weg
finden können wenn man die Details
gehabt hätte hätten wenn man die ähm die
Verdienste der einzelnen Leute gehabt
hätte hätte man besser steuern können
natürlich wäre das gerechter gewesen und
das muss ich als besser verdienen
natürlich zugeben das ist doch
der Wirtschaftsweisen lautet temporär
also nur bis 24 und eben als Energie
Soli muss ja nicht zwingend eine
Steuererhöhung ja muss sich zwingend
eine Steuererhöhung sein ich warne immer
nur davor und jetzt gar in diesem Fall
sondern wir haben insgesamt eine
Situation schon auch als Deutschland
über alle Steuern hinweg dass wir auch
im oecd-bereich Vergleich ziemlich hohe
Steuern schon haben und nochmals wenn
sie mit vielen Investoren aber auch mit
vielen Menschen reden die eben Ausland
überlegen in Deutschland zu investieren
ist das ein Hinderungsgrund von daher
selbst sozusagen einmal Steuern selbst
einmal Solis werden schon kritisch
gesehen von daher muss man das
detailliert prüfen und man sollte hier
nicht sozusagen innerhalb von einem Tag
oder zwei Tagen so eine Entscheidung
fällen ich glaube das bedarf wirklich
eine detaillierten Analysen sie sind
natürlich haben das verfolgt 60% der
deutschen sind nicht mehr
sparfähig das heißt die haben überhaupt
nichts mehr übrig am Ende eines Monats
um noch irgendwas zurückzulegen jenseits
der Ausgaben die sie für das Leben haben
wofür laden Sie die Menschen zum
Weltspartag ein wer ist irgendwie wir
sind es noch ihre Kunden
also die 60 Prozent kenne ich nicht aber
sie haben absolut recht das durch die
Inflation insbesondere der monatliche
Abgleich zwischen Ausgaben und Einnahmen
bei einem erheblichem Anteil unserer
Kunden und damit der gesamten
Bevölkerung nicht mehr aufgeht dass
schwierige und auch das Gefährliche an
dieser Situation ist dass man das jetzt
noch gar nicht in der Nachfrage sieht
denn diese Kunden entsparen gerade durch
die Kurve Zeit haben sich unheimliche
Ersparnisse aufgeben die Kunden konnten
sozusagen gar nicht so viel Geld
ausgeben wie früher und haben viel
gespart jetzt sehen wir eine enorme
entsparung bei unseren Kunden und wenn
man das mal nach vorne projiziert dann
wird es ähm im März April so sein dass
wir wahrscheinlich eine Situation haben
neben der Inflation das ist zu einem
erheblichen Rückgang des Konsums kommt
und das bedeutet übrigens die Rezession
was bedeutet das für diese Kunden genau
das was entschieden worden ist dass
jetzt geholfen werden muss temporär wir
können natürlich nicht dauerhaft Sex
ausstellen das geht nicht deswegen immer
wieder meinen Punkt nach vorne wie
sichern wir die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit von
Deutschland das wirtschaftliche Wachstum
über die Jahre damit wir aus dieser
Unterstützungsleistung aus den
Unterstützungsleistungen herauskommt
aber es ist sicherlich richtig dass wir
zurzeit eine Situation haben wo viele
Menschen nicht mehr sparen können aufs
ersparte zahlen die Banken nach wie vor
kaum Zinsen zum Teil kassieren die
Banken auch Strafzinsen für hinterlegtes
Geld und Kredite werden de facto immer
teurer im Grunde ist es doch jetzt eine
tolle Zeit für Banken oder naja zunächst
einmal möchte ich schon sagen dass wir
sieben Jahre lang Negativzinsen gehabt
haben da hat auch niemand gesagt dass es
eine schwierige Zeit für Bank muss man
uns einstellen aber unsere
Geschäftsmodelle geändert und das ist
eine Situation mit der mussten wir uns
auseinandersetzen ja jetzt haben wir
steigende Zinsen das bedeutet für uns
natürlich in dieser Situation ein
Rückenwind auch vor einer ich kann Ihnen
sagen dass diese Zinsen auch
weitergegeben werden es ist nicht so
dass dann die Negativzinsen einfach
bestehen bleiben und wir nur von den Ste
den Zinsen profitieren natürlich gibt es
jetzt Anpassungen auf der Kreditseite
und das ist natürlich eine Situation der
wir die wir ganz genau beobachten Wert
die Kreditversorgung teurer insbesondere
für den Mittelstand und insbesondere für
die Unternehmen die nicht am
Kapitalmarkt sich refinanzieren können
bei der Frage die geht auch gleich an
den Bundeswirtschaftsminister eine
Bäckerei die Pleite geht eine
Lebensversicherung die zusammenschmilzt
das Haus das nicht abbezahlt werden kann
mit wie vielen echten gefährdeten
Existenzen rechnen sie erleben der
glücklicherweise haben wir erstmal ein
wirklich robustes Kreditportfolio und
ich glaube ich kann das für alle Banken
in Deutschland sagen ob das die
Sparkasse sind die Genossenschaftsbanken
oder die privaten Banken ich glaube die
Banken haben enorm daran gearbeitet in
den letzten 12 Jahren nach der
Finanzkrise einen sauberes kreditbuch zu
haben und das ist wichtig für die
zukünftige Versorgung dass die Banken
auch jetzt in der Lage sind
durchzuffinanzieren das ist wichtig
von daher gehe ich nicht davon aus dass
wir hier wie es oftmal kolportiert wird
eine Pleite Welle sehen ich gehe nicht
davon aus sehen wir höre Insolvenzen
Frau elder im nächsten Jahr natürlich
das wird passieren und wir können auch
die Krise nicht wegdiskutieren aber wir
haben auch keine Weltuntergangsstimmung
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
jetzt für die 12 bis 18 Monate diese
gaspreisbremse haben Liquidität den
Kreditnehmer geben gerade den die es
brauchen und dann müssen wir möglichst
schnell aus dieser wir Fragen gleich
noch mal wie dicht wir eigentlich schon
in der Rezession sind und nicht nur die
Inflation beklagen sondern eben schon
auch eine Rezession und sind erst noch
mal bei den Unternehmen die es auch in
so einer Krise schaffen können die
großen nämlich und bei den kleinen und
mittleren die ist schwerer haben durch
eine Krise zu kommen und die vielleicht
leise sterben oder einfach aufhören zu
produzieren wie sie bei Sandra
Maischberger gesehen und gesagt haben
ist das so dass es die grundsätzlich
auch in dieser Krise leichter haben
werden ich glaube alle haben es schwer
im Moment die
gaspreisbremse und die strompreisbremse
die parallel und ähnlich designt wird
ist aber eine Entlastung nicht von
hundert Prozent das muss man klar sagen
die Logik ist dass man entlang des
Vorschlags wir haben eben gerade diesen
Einspieler gesehen das Verbrauchs von 21
80 Prozent zu einem reduzierten Preis
bekommt 12 bei Gas und 40 12 Cent bei
Gasen 40 sind bei Strom das ist aber
höher als im letzten Jahr
und zwar beides ist höher als im letzten
Jahr das heißt wir verhindern damit dass
die Substanz die volkswirtschaftliche
Substanz des Landes kaputt geht wir
können nicht verhindern dass Unternehmen
höhere Preise haben für die kleineren
und mittleren ist es eine sehr einfache
Logik die müssen nämlich eigentlich gar
nichts tun der das die die Deckelung
oder die Bremse wird von den Versorgern
in der Regel den Stadtwerken ausgestellt
bis zu einem Verbrauch von 1,5 Gigawatt
dann rutscht man ein anderes System aber
selbst dann ist es sehr einfach für die
Verbrauchern Verbraucher inklusive
kleine mittelständischen Unternehmen
inklusive der Wecker das Gesetzeswerk
dahinter ist unendlich kompliziert aber
das ist die abrechnungssystematik
zwischen den Stadtwerken dem Staat und
so weiter das heißt die wird schon
helfen in der Stelle wir haben ich habe
sie nicht grundlos danach gefragt weil
sie ja ausgerechnet dieses Bäcker
Beispiel und die Blumenläden und die
Bioläden erwähnten bei Sandra
Maischberger was wollten sie in der
Situation eigentlich sagen sie sprachen
davon dass die nicht insolvent gehen
sondern dass sie nur nicht weiter
produzieren wollten sie sagen
entschuldigung wenn ich auch das noch
mal Nachfrage dass die in eine temporäre
Pause gehen
das können sich aber auch nicht viele
leisten das schaffen eigentlich auch nur
große weil die kriegen dann
Kurzarbeitergeld und brauchen gute
Rücklagen damit sie durch so eine Zeit
der nicht Produktion kommen oder wollten
sie sagen dass die einfach Ihr Inventar
verkaufen und die Bude zumachen und dann
sind sie einfach weg
der Punkt in der Serien angesprochen hat
der scheint mir volkswirtschaftlich
jetzt oder wirtschaftspolitisch der
entscheidende zu sein wir haben auf der
einen Seite hohe Energiepreise die wir
jetzt dämpfen mit den Gas und den
strompreisbremsen wir haben aber auch
insgesamt eine durch die hohe Inflation
ein Rückgang des verfügbaren zu
konsumierenden Einkommens oder
gegebenenfalls Vermögens das heißt
einige Unternehmen werden einfach durch
die wirtschaftliche Situation in eine
Problemlage geraten weil die Menschen
das Geld zurückhalten gar nicht weil sie
zwingend hohe Energiepreise zu bezahlen
haben die werden auch hohe Energiepreise
zu bezahlen haben aber der
Energieanteil am an den Ausgaben wird
nicht zu hoch sein wie bei einigen
anderen sehr Energie intensiv
produzierenden Unternehmen und trotzdem
mag es sein dass sie ihn Schieflagen
geraden das ist dann eine allgemeine
Gefährdung durch die durch den Schwächen
in Konsum und
im gewissen Sinne
widersprechen sich die Maßnahmen zur
Inflationsbekämpfung und zur
rezessionsbekämpfung Rezession der
wirtschaftliche Einbruch fordert
eigentlich dass der Staat mehr Geld
ausgibt in bestimmte Bereiche rein
investiert die Kaufkraft der Menschen
erhöht und anreizt und also die
Geldmenge in irgendeiner Form erhöht das
hat aber die Inflation und wenn wir
nicht
aufpassen und die politische Kunst wird
im Moment sein
die staatlichen Programme so
auszurichten dass wir in die Bereiche
reingehen die nicht überhitzt sind dass
Sie also mit dem staatlichen Geld das
Konsumverhalten der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger weiter stimulieren
das ist das ist extrem herausfordernd
aber aus meiner Sicht politisch möglich
und ich würde sagen auch geboten und das
darauf wollte ich bei der sagenumwobenen
Maischberger Sendung hin
ja das ist möglich ist genau an den
Stellen den Leuten mit der Liquidität zu
helfen auch den Firmen den kleinen und
Mittelständlern mit der Liquidität zu
helfen und zum anderen Kaufkraft zu
ermöglichen dass der Staat mit seinen
Maßnahmen und entlastungspaketen obwohl
wir ja mit den höheren Zinsen die Segen
eben angesprochen haben eigentlich
verhindern wo also wir will ich mal
nicht sagen aber die die die Logik
dahinter ist die Inflation abzukühlen
trotzdem mit Geld und
Unterstützungsprogramm den
Kaufkraftverlust der Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern reduziert so reduziert
beziehungsweise unterstützen wir können
Herrn seving auch noch mal zitieren sie
haben gesagt ganz kurz noch mal rein
es kann auch nicht der Anspruch sein
dass man alles rettet was in
Schwierigkeiten ist das geht einfach
nicht
so nochmal die Frage was geht nicht zu
retten alles geht nicht zu retten wie
soll mit diesem Jahr beschaubaren
überschaubaren Hilfsgeld der
Bundesregierung wer eigentlich gerettet
werden und wann setzt eine Triage ein
ich glaube zunächst einmal
ist es schon ein Unterschied ob ich
einen großen Unternehmen habe was
internationale aufgestellt ist was auch
die Möglichkeit hat seine Rohmaterial
Rohmaterialien oder seine Produktion zu
verlagern damit vielleicht auch mal die
ein oder anderen Energiepreise
einzusparen oder ob ich den
Mittelständler habe der eine ein Produkt
Strategie hat und ihm das nicht kann von
daher ist es so wichtig dass wir hier
möglichst fokussiert die retten die
jetzt meines Erachtens unverschuldet in
die Krise gekommen ist der zweite Punkt
ist wir dürfen auch wiederum aus
Kapitalmarkt Gründen so ein Programm
nicht dauerhaft laufen lassen ich glaube
es ist enorm wichtig dass wir das Jahr
2023 nutzen um wieder aus dieser
Rezession die kommen wird in 2023
herauszukommen und dann in 20 25 über
ein Wirtschaftswachstum und dann über
wettbewerbsfähige Energiepreise und
natürlich auch eine Energieversorgung in
die Situation kommt dass da genau das
nicht mehr machen müssen Lieferprobleme
wir haben ein Fachkräftemangel wir haben
diese hohen Energiepreise die gleiche
Frage die er habe ich irgendwie versucht
hat schon zu sagen und zu sagen wir
brauchen auch Kaufkraft und es ist ein
eine Gradwanderung wenn das die
Preistreiber sind in der jetzigen
Situation warum soll man dann mit
höheren Zinsen diese Nachfrage noch
abwürgen naja zunächst einmal ist es so
wenn Sie die Inflation jetzt nicht
eindämmen und wir eine Inflation
behalten von 10 oder 11% kommen Sie in
eine Spirale rein aus der sie nicht mehr
rauskommen das haben wir vor 40 oder 50
Jahren gesehen ich glaube gerade unser
Land hat eine Erinnerung was passieren
kann von daher ist es die
vordringlichste Aufgabe diese Inflation
zurückzuführen und Herren wir sprechen
nicht davon dass man auf einen
Inflationsziel von zwei Prozent im
nächsten Jahr kommt das wäre
unrealistisch aber wir müssen es wieder
schaffen genau wir müssen 24 müssen auf
unter 5% kommen ich glaube da besteht
auch eine gute Chance und ich glaube
auch mit der gaspreisbremse haben wir
auch eine Chance die Inflation die wir
ursprünglich für neun bis zehn Prozent
nächstes Jahr gesehen haben zumindest
auf sieben oder siebeneinhalb Prozent zu
drücken und ich glaube einfach das ist
jetzt die vordringlichste Aufgabe dass
wir das schaffen damit diese Spirale und
diese lobpreisspirale eben nicht
eintritt das wäre eine Gefahr denn dann
kommen sie aus der Situation ganz
interessant dass sie sagen Warnstreik
der Metaller jetzt Plus 8%, ist in ihren
Augen zu viel oder zu wenig naja was
heißt es ist natürlich eine ich kann das
einfach aus der Deutschen Bank sagen
wenn sie auf einmal Lohnkosten bei uns
65% unserer Kosten sind Lohnkosten wenn
wir anstatt eines normalen
Tarifabschlusses von zwei oder drei
Prozent fünf Prozent drauf schreiben
dann haben sie natürlich sofort eine
Frage der Rentabilität aber trotzdem
Boni aus in 2,1 Milliarden Höhe und 700
Millionen Dividende in 2021 ja das
können wir 20 Bürgern aber wir können
das in 2021 haben wir das gemacht auf
jeden Fall wir ein sehr ordentliches
Jahr gehabt haben aber natürlich wird
sowas immer jährlich überprüfen es
müssen wir überprüfen immer vor dem
Hintergrund was haben wir verdient wie
ist der wirtschaftliche Ausblick wie ist
die Kapitalsituation des Unternehmens
von daher ist das immer eine bewusste
und eine sehr dezidierte Entscheidung
die wir treffen 8% mehr bei den
Metallern ist zu viel Herr Habeck oder
dürfen die das wir haben Tarifautonomie
und das bedeutet dass sich die Politik
der gerne raushalten sollen das will ich
auch tun
ich will nur darauf hinweisen dass die
staatlichen Programme wenn es darum geht
den Kaufkraftverlust durch Lohnerhöhung
auszugleichen da auch eine Wirkung haben
das ist ja das was die Bundesregierung
mit der sogenannten konzentrierten
Aktion adressiert hat also ein
Gesprächskreis würde ich mal
respektierlich nennen zwischen
Gewerkschaften Arbeitgeber verbinden und
anderen Akteuren Wirtschaft und
Wissenschaft und so weiter dazwischen
und die Maßnahmen die wir ergriffen
haben
von den Erhöhung der der
Sozialbeiträge bis zu den steuerlichen
Maßnahmen und so weiter die Sorgen ja
dafür dass der Kaufkraftverlust durch
Inflation jetzt schon durch
fiskalpolitische Maßnahmen geringert
wird und ansonsten ist es den
Gewerkschaften und den Arbeitgebern
Arbeitnehmern in guter Tradition
freigestellt die Branchen zu bewerten
die Gewinne der Branchen jeweils
unterschiedlich zu analysieren und dann
ihre Tarifverhandlung zu führen und habe
ich sondern Herr sebing unter Lindner
sagen zusammen Inflationsbekämpfung ist
Aufgabe Nummer 1 sagt dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ja und es gibt
zeitgleich eine zweite Aufgabe die
Rezession nicht tief und lang werden zu
lassen und das
anspruchsvolle in dieser Situation ist
dass beides parallel passiert wir haben
10% Inflation
nun haben wir die Daten für das letzte
Quartal noch nicht aber wahrscheinlich
beginnende Rezession und wenn wir
die Inflation nur runter kriegen um den
Preis einer schweren Wirtschaftskrise
also wirklich dann
Insolvenzen Betriebsschließungen
Arbeitslosigkeit dann wird es gefährlich
dann haben wir das Kind mit dem Bade
ausgeschüttet und deswegen und das ist
auch das gehört zu der Situation die
fordern und neues deswegen müssen wir
zwei Strategien gleichzeitig fahren
so ähnlich wie Gas einkaufen und dann
erneuerbare Energien ausbauen
und dass das gelingen kann
zeigt meine ich
zeigen die Maßnahmen die wir beschlossen
haben mit der Gas und Strompreis Bremse
dämpfen wir die Inflation sie wird
grober Daum knapp zwei Prozent dadurch
runtergehen wir werden gucken wie es im
konkreten wirkt und gleichzeitig bleibt
mehr Geld zum Konsumieren über und die
Menschen können damit wenn sie gegenüber
den Preissteigerung noch einmal das habe
ich jetzt falsch formuliert es bleibt
ihm nicht mehr Geld über das wird ja
trotzdem teurer werden aber es wird mehr
Geld über bleiben als würde man die
Preise voll durchschlagen lassen so dass
wir den kompletten Kaufkraft Verlust
etwas abfedern etwas abbremsen und aber
nicht vollständig ersetzen können diese
Wirtschaftsweisen haben
noch ein weiteres Nest gelegt und zwar
nicht nur Herrn Lindner das mit den
Reichen sondern auch den Grünen die
Frage der Atomenergie
die Kommission die Wirtschaftsweisen
schlagen vor länger Atomenergie zu
brauchen es würde viel schneller
natürlich eine größere Preissenkung
geben am Markt es gibt die bekannten
Argumente selbst Greta findet das
Atomenergie jetzt nicht Bombe ist aber
Atomenergie kann eine Lösung sein in
dieser Krise und es ist viel mehr als
Kohle was sagen sie
ich will jetzt kein Experte für die
beste Energieversorgung oder für den
besten Energie-Mix aber sicherlich aber
sicherlich habe ich ähm bin ich da auch
etwas anderer Meinung als der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dass ich
glaube gerade in der Situation in der
wir jetzt sind sollten wir keine
Alternative ausschlagen wir haben eine
Situation wo wir enorm hohe Preise haben
wo wir gerade die ganze Zeit darüber
gesprochen haben wie sehr unsere
Unternehmen oder Verbraucher für diese
Preise zahlen und wie hoch sie zahlen
von daher ist es glaube ich wichtig dass
man jetzt an diesem Punkt keine
Alternative ausschlägt dass wir auf
Dauer in einen Weg und einem Pfad
reinkommen die erneuerbaren Energien
nach vorne zu stellen die übrigens dann
auch vom preiswert natürlich
nicht nur eine Alternative sind sondern
auch wettbewerbsfähig sind ist
vollkommen klar aber jetzt
auszuschließen halte ich persönlich auch
aus der gesamten Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
die ich für die nächstes Jahr sehe und
auch übrigens für den kommenden Winter
halte ich für Fragen auch da sind wir
sehr von China abhängig dazu kommen
dennoch er habe ich diese
das Machtwort des Kanzlers müssen wir
noch besprechen sagen sie da auch das
ist
rückwärtsgewandt und egal wie auch immer
ich frage es einfach trotzdem
wann wussten Sie dass das mit dem
Dezember und abschalten im Dezember
nicht klappt
Abschalten der drei Atomkraftwerke nicht
klappt
dass das nicht reich wird
nach dem nach der Lektüre des
Stresstestes klar dass wir unter
bestimmten Voraussetzungen in eine Netz
Engpasssituation kommen können wo die
drei Atomkraftwerke oder die zwei im
Süden vor allem und das dritte schadet
nicht helfen können das war dann jetzt
muss ich zurückdenken war das Ende
August oder Anfang September ich glaube
Ende August war an der dritte ist das
vorgelegt so und waren sie und Christian
Lindner dann besonders erleichtert als
der Kanzler für sie beide eine Lösung
fand
eine Lösung für das Land und eine Lösung
für diese Regierung
und denken Sie auch wie Herr sewing dass
es ganz klug sein könnte dass länger zu
tun als ausgerechnet für vier Monate
zu Ende ist heißt ja auch dass sie zu
Ende ist so wünschen sie sich das und
dennoch könnte es ja sein dass man in
eine Situation kommt dass noch mal
aufzumachen das glaube ich nicht dass
die Richtlinienkompetenz hat ja in zwei
Richtungen gewirkt einmal drei AKWs
laufen bis Mitte April weiter
und danach laufen sie nicht weiter da
steht dabei das da drin steht beides da
drin hat sie der Bundeskanzler damit vor
einem Gesichtsverlust bewahrt oder vor
einer Peinlichkeit nein das ist die
Möglichkeit die Olaf Scholz hat und wir
wollen doch alle ein Kanzler der von
seinen Möglichkeiten Gebrauch machen das
ist richtig und dann ist trotzdem
interessant dass Robert Habeck anbietet
einen Deal mit ihnen zu machen
ich wäre sofort bereit zu sagen wir
machen in Deutschland ein Tempolimit
wenn die Kernkraftwerke länger laufen
ja also ich weiß nicht wie das gemeint
sind Robert habe
da ist Robert Habeck da war Christian
Lindner gerade in der Kamera ist es ein
Deal sie werden das Thema einfach nicht
loswerden doch sind sie ganz sicher
naja sie machen ja ihre Sendung selber
das könnt ihr selber entscheiden wie das
Thema weiter läuft aber ich kann Ihnen
sagen warum das Thema im nächsten Winter
anders bearbeitet wird weil es der
schwierigere Winter wird weil wir
vielleicht Atomkraftwerke brauchen weil
wir in diesem Winter das sagte der
Stresstest dann muss man auch also wenn
man sozusagen sich fordert wenn man sie
fordert sich mit den Fakten
auseinandersetzen muss man das Ding auch
lesen sagt es werden gegebenenfalls vier
Extremszenarien zusammengekommen außer
der französischen atomflotte
die Kohlekraftwerke die wir aus der
Reserve rausgeholt haben werden
unterversorgt weil der Rhein nicht genug
Wasser führt möglicherweise Mangel an
Wasserkraft und dass der entscheidende
Punkt und die Gaskraftwerke wären
unterversorgt wegen fehlendem russischen
Gas und man kann jetzt schwer sagen wie
die Franzosen ihre atomproblemen in den
Griff bekommen man weiß auch nicht genau
ob die der nächste Mal wieder trocken
wird und die Wasserkraftwerke voll sind
dass die Kohlekraftwerke die jetzt da
sind eine bessere Vorsorge Situation
haben ist mehr als wahrscheinlich denn
der rein oder die anderen Flüsse sind
jetzt befahrbar und wir haben auch die
Transportwege auf der Schiene noch mal
priorisiert also da ist viel Arbeit
geleistet worden der Unterschied wird
sein dass wir über das nächste Jahr
weitere gaskapazitäten dazu bekommen wir
werden nicht nur die drei Projekte die
wir jetzt zum Jahreswechsel an den
norddeutschen Küsten dazu bekommen
sondern auch noch dann weitere 4
Projekte so dass ein Großteil des
Ausfalls des russischen gases erledigt
ersetzt werden kann und das wird zu
einer anderen Versorgungssituation zu
einer sehr sicheren Versorgungssituation
auch der Gaskraftwerke auch um
süddeutschen Raum führen und das macht
den Unterschied zum Jahr 22 23 aus
deswegen
denke ich schon dass Leute weiter ihrer
Meinung vertreten werden aber die Sorge
dass wir ein Netz Engpass oder ein ein
Stabilitätsproblem im Netz bekommen weil
die Gaskraftwerke nicht vernünftig
laufen die ist deutlich geringer im
Grunde ist sie damit genommen sie ist
genommen und noch mal die Frage Angebote
eines Deals sie lesen natürlich auch was
die Öffentlichkeit von den Journalisten
Kollegen erfährt die Grünen
beerburg Trittin und Hasselmann
haben sie dazu gezwungen mit diesem
Parteitagsbeschluss quasi in die
Verhandlungen zu gehen und sie mussten
ihre pragmatische Lösung vergessen was
sagt Robert habe angesprochen ich bin
der Meinung dass ein Tempolimit in ganz
Europa gilt Deutschland gut tun wird und
zwar
alles gut
ich verstehe jeden der gerne schnell
nach Hause kommt und keine schnell fährt
aber das tue ich übrigens auch wenn ich
wenn ich ich habe auch keine Lust lange
auf der Autobahn zu sein aber hier geht
es um was anderes ich warte auch nicht
gern in der Supermarkt Schlange und
schubst deswegen trotzdem nicht alle
anderen Weg aber ich komme so deswegen
finde ich sehr dafür das zu machen aber
wir haben uns nicht im Koalitionsvertrag
auf ein Tempolimit geeinigt und in der
in der Bedeutung in der Wirksamkeit ist
das das weiß auch kein nichts also
nichts was was ernsthaft diskutiert wird
die Debatte die Atome Debatte ist aus
meiner Sicht für diese Koalition mit der
Ansage von Olaf Scholz erledigt
und wenn man die Autorität wenn man die
Autorität ist kann es nicht beschädigen
will hält man sich auch an das was
entschieden wurde okay und sie bedauern
im Nachhinein oder Bedauern nicht dass
sie gegebenenfalls eine andere Lösung
präferiert hätten sie der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
Vizekanzler dieses Landes als mit dem
Parteitagsbeschluss zu dem sie so
schreiben kluge Journalisten Kollegen
von Jürgen Trittin von Annalena baerbock
und von Frau Hasselmann gezwungen wurden
dann in diese Verhandlung zu gehen
selber eine adäquate Lösung für den
Winter eine mit der alle okay leben
können und da ist eine Lösung ist sollte
es auch bei der Lösung bleiben es ist
eine Lösung für vier Monate und dazu
brauchte es ein Kanzler Machtwort wie
beschädigt ist diese Bundesregierung
wenn es für das vier Monate weiterlaufen
von Atomkraftwerken das macht Wort eines
Kanzlers die Richtlinienkompetenz
braucht na ja am Ende des Tages ist es
wichtig dass eine Entscheidung getroffen
ist und die wurde getroffen
vielleicht etwas zu spät da ist
natürlich auch eine Frage die immer
wieder vom Ausland gestellt wird wann
wird entschieden aber es ist jetzt eine
Entscheidung getroffen worden und damit
gibt es eine Art Planungssicherheit ich
glaube worüber wir viel mehr reden
müssen ist wie stellen wir die
langfristige Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Deutschland sicher die ausländischen
Investoren Fragen eigentlich nur eins
sie glauben uns dass wir durch die
nächsten 12 Monate kommen ich glaube all
das was jetzt entschieden worden ist das
die Gasspeicher zu 100% voll sind ist
gut Gaspreis Bremse ist gut die
Kernfrage ist eine andere wie stellen
wir für dieses Land was ein Industrie
Land bleiben wird wie stellen wir sicher
dass wir Energiepreise wettbewerbsfähig
haben da brauchen wir einen Plan da
brauchen wir klare Aussagen nur dann
werden wir auch wieder eine
Investitionsbank sein und darüber müssen
wir sprechen und die klar machen wir
jetzt unsere sagen dass einzelne
Produktionsweisen so ist Robert habe ich
zu zitieren einzelne Produktionslinien
Deutschland verlassen könnten dass das
dazu kommen wird auch auch mit den
Investitionshilfen die es durch die
Bundesregierung gibt darüber habe ich
nicht gesagt kommen kann Gefahr besteht
natürlich genau also eine Industrie die
ihr Geschäftsmodell auf der Verarbeitung
von russischem Gas aufgebaut hat ist
realerweise jetzt für eine
Herausforderung weil das ist russische
Gas nicht gibt das ist so kommen muss
habe ich mit keinem Wort gesagt ist auch
überhaupt nicht das Ziel sondern es geht
jetzt darum schnell zu transformieren
und das gelingt auch es gibt eine
wie ich fand sehr erstaunlich Analyse
die produzierende Industrie hat in den
letzten Monaten 25% Gas eingespart aber
nur 1,4% weniger produziert man würde
eigentlich denken ach so 25% weniger Gas
heißt ungefähr 25% weniger Produktion
ist aber nicht der Fall natürlich ist
auch viel der sogenannte fuel Switch
also Umstellung von Gas auf Öl
beispielsweise aber es wird nicht alles
sein das heißt wir haben die Möglichkeit
mit Energieeffizienz mit neuen Techniken
mit
Elektrifizierung und dem schnellen
Einsatz und dem Hochlauf von Wasserstoff
beispielsweise Alternativen zu schaffen
dass das ein Prozess ist das ist also
nicht ach heute so morgen so ist sondern
eine Zeit dauert das ist ohne Frage so
deswegen hängt alles davon ab dass diese
Zeit kurz gemacht wird und wenn es etwas
gibt vor einem tragischen Hintergrund
und bitte nicht als zynisch
missverstehen was in diesem Land gerade
passiert ist ist das tiefe Verständnis
dass wir keine Zeit mehr haben dass die
Gesellschaft ein ich meine einen Konsens
hat das bestimmte
Verfahrensdauern in sich begründet
vielleicht ein recht haben aber
insgesamt zu keinem akzeptablen Ergebnis
führen weil sich nichts bewegt weil die
Stromnetze die Elektrolyse die der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
von Glasfaserkabeln alles zu lange
dauert und in diesem Jahr sind wir da
enorm vorangekommen wenn wir die
Erfahrung die wir jetzt punktuell bei
bestimmten Sachen gesammelt haben nutzen
um die Transformation der Energie der
Industrie auch der voranzubringen dann
werden wir das schaffen und dann muss
die Industrie nicht abwandern sondern
sie wird anders produzieren wir hören
noch mal in Wolfgang große entrop rein
der ist der Chef des Verbandes der
chemischen Industrie weil tatsächlich
Chemie Glas zementstahl ähm
befürchten dass sie eben wegen der hohen
in der Energiepreise entweder in
Richtung Amerika auswandern oder in
Richtung Asien auswandern wir hören ganz
kurz noch mal dem Kollegen
vom Chemieverband zu
einzelne Wertschöpfungsketten beginnen
schon zu reißen wir befürchten deshalb
nicht nur eine Rezession sondern die
d-industriealisierung des Landes
es gibt einen großen Unterschied
zwischen geordneter Transformation und
schockartiger disruption die soziale
Verwerfungen und große Schäden
verursachen kann dazu darf es nicht
kommen
das war Siegfried Russwurm der bdi-chef
Herr seligen die Gefahr das hat der
Kollege vom VCI noch angefügt dass wir
zu einem Industriemuseum mutieren dieser
groß wie schockgefroren sind ihre
Kollegen in Anbetracht dieser Welt
Situation dass die USA 430 Milliarden
ein Anti inflationspaket auflegen und
damit locken und das ist auf der anderen
Seite in Asien und auch in China
natürlich genau diese Angebote ja ich
das kann nur eins sein das kann unser
Ansporn nur sein etwas ähnliches in
Europa und in Deutschland zu machen ich
sage immer wir brauchen die europäische
Souveränität wir brauchen eine
europäische Agenda wo genau ähnlich
investiert wird in die Technologien wo
wir Vorreiter sind und was mich in einem
Beispiel geben
nachhaltigkeitstechnologien ist Europa
ein klarer Vorreiter Europa hat dort
Technologien die in der Welt sozusagen
von uns genommen werden wollen die wir
exportieren können und da müssen wir
jetzt es gibt punktuell 750 Milliarden
sogar aus Europa dieses große
corona-paket ja das next Gent Paket aber
ganz ehrlich gesagt die die europäische
Wirtschaft auf den Green Deal
umzuwandeln bzw wird länger dauern und
wird noch viel viel mehr Milliarden
kosten aber genau da müssen wir jetzt
anfangen zu investieren und ja auch mit
besseren Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten wie
sie Amerikaner uns vormachen aber ich
glaube ich warne davor dass wir hier ein
Abgesang auf die Industrie in
Deutschland machen natürlich müssen wir
uns ändern natürlich müssen
Genehmigungsverfahren noch weiter ähm
beschleunigt werden das hoch die
Lieferketten Probleme also das war ja
der Punkt
Probleme Lieferketten Probleme sind noch
da aber das liegt natürlich auch in der
Verantwortung von uns Unternehmen da
wieder zu organisieren und auch da haben
wir die Unternehmen eine Flexibilität
gezeigt schauen sich im März die
Kabelbaum Probleme an bei den ähm
automotive auch das haben wir versucht
und die Unternehmen wir haben es ja auch
glaube ich ganz gut gemanagt bekommen
das hinzubekommen von daher hier ist
eine enorme Kraft in diesem Land ich
glaube wir dürfen jetzt auch wirklich
nicht in diesen Abgesang kommen nur wenn
wir jetzt nicht uns Gedanken machen wie
wir ab dem Winter 2023 24 wieder in ein
normales Wirtschaften kommen ohne die
Pakete des Haushalts denn der ist nun
mal endlich das wissen wir alle
dann kommen wir in eine Situation rein
wo wir ein eigenes wirtschaftliches
Wachstum nicht haben und das nämlich das
noch sagen Freunde wir überlegen immer
was wir alles machen müssen wir werden
100 Milliarden meines Erachtens
richtigerweise in die Verteidigung
investiert werden andere Programme
gemacht die Basis dafür ist
wirtschaftliche Stabilität und Wachstum
muss und deswegen ohne diese Gesetz klar
und deswegen müssen wir jetzt anfangen
neben der Inflationsbekämpfung
langfristig zu investieren und das in
Europa
sie haben den Bundeskanzler nach China
begleitet sie waren in diese sehr
besonderen Reise um nicht zu sagen in
einer fast heiklen Mission weil es ja
auch darum ging ähm deutlich zu machen
dass wir uns eigentlich andere Kriterien
des Handels wünschen Robert habe der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat bei VW
eine Bürgschaft für eine Investition von
dem Autobauer
untersagt und beschränkt wenn es diese
Bürgschaften der Bundesregierung nicht
mehr gibt ist es dann für Sie noch läuft
kreditieren sie VW noch in China also
sie werden verstehen dass sie jetzt
nicht über einzelne Adressen spreche
aber lassen Sie mich mal anders über
China reden ich glaube wir sollten
vorsichtig sein China ist weiterhin und
wird weiterhin ein Kernmarkt für
deutsche Unternehmen sein nicht nur im
Sinne von Markt nach Nachfrage sondern
natürlich auch in der Beschaffung von
Rohstoffen ich glaube was wichtig ist
dass wir weiter fangen und den Weg gehen
der Diversifizierung und das ist
natürlich das ist das erste Einzel eins
dass sie als Risiko Manager einer einer
Bank lernt dass wir nicht so abhängig
sind von daher ist es wichtig dass wir
in andere Märkte in andere Märkte
investieren deswegen war es auch richtig
dass wir in Asien jetzt waren und andere
Märkte wie Indonesien Thailand Vietnam
uns ansehen um zu suchen inkrementierte
Märkte zu bekommen aber wir können
einfach in einer Wirtschaft in der wir
sind und wie verflochten wir sind
brauchen wir China und wird China wird
ein wichtiger Markt sein und deswegen
halte ich auch überhaupt nichts von den
Diskussion von die Caplin
Diversifizierung aber kein dekabeln also
keine Auflösung oder Trennung und nicht
nur zusammenarbeitung mit Zusammenarbeit
mit
Kanada und USA beispielsweise also mit
unseren Freunden müsste man erklären
dass es mit decathling gemeint Habeck
sie sehen das ein bisschen kritischer
Mädchen nein im Wesentlichen siehst du
wie wir sehen okay und sie sagen welches
sind die Kriterien nach denen die
Bundesregierung Investment in China
ermöglicht und erlaubt China wird ein
wichtiger Partner bleiben ein
Absatzmarkt für deutsche Produkte und
ein auch ein Markt Ost oder ein Land aus
dem wir Rohstoffe und Produkte
importieren werden
zwei Dinge müssen sich ändern meiner
Ansicht nach wir müssen die kritischen
Infrastrukturen und Industriebereiche
in Deutschland oder in Europa schützen
vor Interessen Einfluss der dass ich
gegen uns richten kann deswegen das aber
jetzt noch nicht das Handelsgeschäft mit
China sondern sozusagen
Industrie
halbleiterindustriebereiche der
Gesundheitswirtschaft vielleicht wo
medizinische Produkte produziert werden
ist wird andere geben
Kommunikationstechnik
Energieversorgungssysteme
und das ist ein Prozess weil wir uns
damit nie beschäftigt haben wir haben
das wissen sie weil auch der Markt
nichts anderes teilweise hergibt da
immer wieder locker chinesische Technik
eingebaut da sollten wir eine eigene
europäische Widerstandsfähigkeit
aufbauen in diesem Bereichen die wird
etwas mehr kosten das ist ja ein
marktbetriebenes Geschehen deswegen ist
die ganze Technik nach China gewandert
trotzdem ist es richtig also da muss man
aufpassen und der Handel mit China wie
gesagt wird weitergehen aber
er sollte die Abhängigkeit von China
nicht vergrößern das heißt wissend dass
China nicht verschwinden wird und auch
das Geschäft mit China nicht
verschwinden wird sollte nicht noch
politisch gefördert werden und das ist
der Unterschied dass die Abhängigkeit
also die an zu einer das ist zu einer
Abhängigkeit kommt und deswegen werden
wir
exportgarantien nicht nur wie das war ja
der Grund ja und wir sagen bei VW
anstrenger an Menschenrechtsverstößen
ausrichten also an Menschenrechten
ausrichten und bei Menschenrechts
Verstößen sanktionieren Uiguren sondern
auch Deckeln so dass man nicht alle
seine
Investition im Ausland
staatlich geschützt in einem Land in
diesem Fall China machen kann wenn man
es trotzdem tut okay und dann nehmen wir
richtig Entscheidung aber wahrscheinlich
werden Unternehmen dann ihre
Entscheidung anders treffen weil das
schon sehr wichtig ist dass der Staat
immer sagt wenn schief geht dann kaufen
wir euch raus und wenn man das dann
weiter haben will wird man
diversifizieren müssen okay und das
Annalena baerburg jetzt in Sharm el
Sheikh ist und darüber mit auf dieser
großen Klimakonferenz diskutiert mit den
Kollegen aus aller Welt und sie hier zu
Hause sich um die gasumlage kümmern ist
ein Problem innerhalb der Grünen Partei
von Ihnen beiden überhaupt nicht also
wir haben das ja so geeint dass das
Außenministerium wegen der
diplomatischen Bedeutung also der
diplomatischen Bedeutung die
Klimakonferenz organisiert und das macht
sie bestimmt super und deswegen gibt es
eine Arbeitsteilung wird es diese
menschenrechtsgeleitete Außenpolitik
auch in der Wirtschaft geben können wird
es nur noch Blitz saubere Geschäfte
geben können in der Welt dann müsste man
die Kataris nicht bitten und die Sau
dies nicht und Herr sie würde
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viel Geld
verdienen
ich glaube zu Ehrlichkeit gehört dass
das hohe Ziel einer Werte geleiteten
außen oder meinetwegen auch
Wirtschaftspolitik sich immer mit den
Realitäten wird auseinandersetzen müssen
ja und der ist auch so gemeint das heißt
wenn man sich selbst die Latte zu hoch
liegt wird man am Ende nur unter ihr
durchlaufen können das heißt aber nicht
dass der absolute Relativismus regieren
muss wir sind in der Lage bestimmte
Entscheidungen wo wirklich krasse
Menschenrechtsverstöße da sind auch zu
treffen gegen die Interessen von
wirtschaftlich und das müssen wir auch
tun wenn die USA wir können allerdings
nicht nur mit uns selber Handeln
betreiben wenn die USA uns zu Sanktionen
gegenüber China zwingen und auf der
anderen Seite aber gerade nicht so
richtig interessiert an Saudi-Arabien
sind lösen wir das wie oft als deutsche
Bundesregierung wir sind insgesamt meine
ich auch mit Blick auf das was in
Amerika passieren kann gut beraten die
europäische Souveränität also eine
verschiedene Linie eine eigene
politische Kraft zu stärken das ist in
der Krise übrigens passiert bei allen
Problemen die die Staaten manchmal
untereinander haben jedenfalls im
Energiebereich den Bereich den ich
überschaue und wo ich jetzt auf vielen
Konferenzen weiß Europa in einer
Geschwindigkeit zusammengewachsen und
wurde die Leitrolle der Europäischen
Kommission als Rahmen akzeptiert wie das
vorher nicht denkbar und die Länder
fangen jetzt auf einmal an und zwar
Länder die sich auch sehr abgeriegelt
haben
interkonnektoren also Grenzübergänge
zwischen den Stromleitungen den
gasnetzen zu bauen sich gegenseitig zu
unterstützen
immer gut da drin zu sagen wir sind
quasi eine Insel in Europa am besten
kümmern wir uns nur um uns selbst im
Energiebereich das ist weg sie helfen
uns wir helfen denen das ist das ist gut
aber natürlich ist es noch lange nicht
zu Ende gedacht also um es einmal
auszusprechen was passiert wäre denn
gewesen wenn Donald Trump die letzten
zwei Jahre oder im letzten Präsident
gewesen wäre was würde passieren wenn
die liberale Führungsmacht der Welt das
darf man wohl sagen das ist Amerika noch
immer
auf einmal Sympathien für Chie und Putin
haben würde was machen wir dann und ich
glaube dass die einzige Antwort ist dass
Europa sich zusammenreißen muss jetzt
steht ja auch und tatsächlich zu einer
alles handelt von Handlungsfähigkeit von
der Bundesregierung der deutschen
Demokratie der Republik in der wir leben
aber auch Europa und Europa muss Kraft
finden schneller Entschlüsse zu fassen
schneller gemeinsam zu agieren braucht
dafür ein politisches Mandat muss ich so
reformieren dass Europa als als geeinte
Stimme in der Welt wahrgenommen wird und
auch so handelt wenn ich ein letztes
sagen darf weil Herr sieding doch und
das betrifft die Wirtschaftsförderung
das Geld ist gar nicht das Problem Geld
geben wir auch in wahnsinnigen Höhen aus
aber wir müssen alles 10.000 mal
überprüfen und notifizieren und die
Amerikaner haben ein Gesetz geschrieben
das das ist die förderkulis daran hältst
Christus es geht halt daran sind schnell
während wir brauchen noch drei Umwege um
Block laufen und noch mal prüfen ob wir
auch alles richtig beant heilen konnten
wir uns dabei das können wir uns nicht
mehr leisten in Teilen konnten wir uns
dabei zugucken ich darf mich sehr
herzlich und sehr schnell für dieses
Gespräch bedanken Markus Lanz ist in der
Spur vielen dank der hat heute unter
anderem Markus Söder zu Gast und wir
sehen uns nächste Woche nicht aber wenn
sie möchten in der Woche darauf gleiche
Stelle gleiche Welle sie kommen gut
durch diesen Abend und bis in 14 Tagen
und ihnen beiden sehr